[Música]
llegó el momento de revista de prensa
con rosa pérez es más de euros a
bienvenida feliz viernes muy buen día
vamos a empezar hablando del repaso de
la prensa argentina que titula con el
cierre de la campaña electoral de cara a
los comicios de este domingo rosa buenos
días raúl feliz viernes exacto nos hemos
querido fijar en la prensa argentina que
está muy pendiente de estas elecciones
legislativas del domingo y sobre todo
porque puede suponer esto para el
gobierno de alberto fernández porque
recordemos el 12 de septiembre tras las
primarias de estas mismas legislativas
el oficialismo salió muy perjudicado
mientras que la fuerza del opositor y ex
presidente mauricio macri se vio
reforzada y eso desató precisamente una
crisis interna dentro del propio
gobierno entre el presidente alberto
fernández y la vicepresidenta cristina
fernández de kirchner y con eso es con
lo que titula precisamente clarín el
primer medio con el que nos hemos fijado
respecto al acto de cierre de campaña
alberto fernández buscó ahuyentar los
fantasmas de ruptura con cristina
kirchner y dentro del texto
a 72 horas de una elección crucial los
máximos referentes del oficialismo
buscaron enviar un mensaje de unidad que
quedó desdibujado por los gestos y los
trascendidos ministros de peso
estuvieron ausentes y los presentes
llegaron y se fueron por separado y
luego seguimos con la nación que dice un
oficialismo con los números en contra y
no se refiere solamente a los sondeos
raúl sino también a la crisis económica
los índices de pobreza la inflación o la
renegociación del pago de la deuda de
argentina con el fmi y precisamente con
la deuda cerramos también es lo que
destaca página 12 que dice
titula digamos una frase de alberto
fernández no vamos a resolver la deuda
con el fm y en 5 minutos
y también señala que admitió alberto
fernández en este acto de cierre de
campaña que muchos argentinos no han
notado la recuperación
económica pero que va a hacer todo lo
posible para poder mirar a cada
argentino a los ojos rosa vamos ahora
con el 'new york times' la conexión de
bolsonaro trump amenaza las elecciones
de brasil por
bien está esta investigación lo que
señala es que bolsonaro está siguiendo
la misma estrategia de cara a los
comicios presidenciales de 2022 que
siguió donald trump de cara a las
elecciones presidenciales
estadounidenses de 2020 y es esta
deslegitimación ante las elecciones de
forma anticipada no ya está señalado que
van a hacer ya está señalando que van a
hacer un robo y para esta campaña de
hecho cuenta con el apoyo del círculo
del ex presidente de donald trump que
mantiene una afinidad ideológica con el
presidente bolsonaro y también pues sus
apoyos políticos pero además comparten
muchos intereses económicos y de hecho
para la extrema derecha estadounidense
brasil es una pieza clave en esta
alianza internacional de extrema derecha
y el procedimiento dice para
deslegitimar ya estas elecciones como
comentábamos de forma anticipada según
el 'new york times' es etiquetar a sus
rivales políticos como criminales y
comunistas construyendo nuevas redes
sociales donde pueden esquivar las
formas contra la desinformación de
silicon baile perdón contra la
desinformación de silicon valley y
pueden amplificar sus afirmaciones de
que las elecciones de brasil serán
manipuladas rosa a propósito del fin de
la cob 26 que termina hoy en glasgow en
escocia vamos con un artículo del país
que hace jorge galindo y se titula el
aire que mata en américa latina' exacto
este texto hace referencia no sólo a los
gases de efecto invernadero como son el
co2 sino otras partículas que se
encuentran elena en el aire que son a la
spm 25 que provienen pues de login por
ejemplo contienen ciertos metales y que
no llegan a causar el efecto invernadero
porque se mantienen muy poco tiempo en
la atmósfera pero si son perjudiciales
para las personas que las respiran y
señala la contaminación bien ambiental y
el cambio climático son dos caras de la
misma moneda la buena noticia es que
luchar contra uno de estos factores
también es luchar contra el otro la mala
noticia es que mientras no se solucione
uno tampoco se soluciona el otro y aquí
vemos muchos mapas y gráficos sobre cómo
afecta la contaminación ambiental a
distintos puntos de américa latina pero
sobre todo constatamos un factor clave
es que está muy relacionada con el
desarrollo económico por dos lados por
un lado porque en un primer lugar el
desarrollo económico suele estar muy
vinculado con el uso de combustibles
fósiles lo que genera mucha
contaminación ambiental pero también las
regiones con más ingresos también son
las que pueden llegar a sustituir el
primer más rápidamente las necesidades
energéticas con fuentes de energía menos
contaminantes no por ejemplo en los
hogares sustituir la leña pues por otras
formas de conseguir electricidad y un
dato muy relevante es que en méxico y
raúl uno de cada 18 fallecidos tiene que
ver con la contaminación ambiental rosa
ya para finalizar rápidamente vamos a
mexico el universal desde acoso a
suministro es lo que sufren las
empleadas de la riviera maya este es una
investigación muy profunda para la que
este medio mexicano ha contado con
decenas de entrevistas a trabajadores y
trabajadoras sobre todo del sector
turístico en la rivera maya que es la
región más turística del país también
donde se registra más violencia sexual y
menos denuncias las autoridades
ocurre según señala esta investigación
es que muchas de estas trabajadoras son
violentadas y estos crímenes quedan
impunes
completamente porque en muchos casos son
trabajadoras migrantes que están
desamparadas de cara a la justicia con
pocos apoyos apoyos sociales también y
da pues a testigos raúl que son pues
desgarradores pues qué casos de
violaciones en que las trabajadoras son
indemnizadas con una pequeña suma a
cambio de que no denuncien al turista de
turno que las ha violentado y a cambio
de que no denuncien a la policía
lamentable situación rosa muchísimas
gracias por todos estos artículos de la
prensa internacional que usted nos ha
traído hoy viernes sabemos el lunes con
más revista de prensa ahora vamos con
nuestro primer invitado el día